invité dans votre agenda et une ue tube
québécoises dont la chaîne suivi par des
centaines de milliers d'internautes est
spécialisé dans les cas de meurtres et
de disparitions mystérieuses
mais avant de parler de disparition
saluons comme il se doit
l'apparition de victoria charge
[Musique]
allez-vous alors ayez quelque chose
d'étrange dans votre trajectoire si vous
avez commencé par des vidéos qui n'avait
rien à voir avec les disparitions et les
moeurs était plutôt du genre
humoristique et puis vous êtes venu à
vous intéresser à ces faits divers
particulièrement dure comment s'est fait
ce passage mais j'ai toujours eu un
intérêt pour ces histoires c'est parce
que j'ai grandi avec
bon vous connaissez pas canal d on
obtient à l'investigation au québec et
j'ai lu beaucoup de livres sur le sujet
et j'ai découvert une histoire qui
s'appelle baisser la disparition d'élise
alarme une jeune fille qui a disparu à
los angeles et je suis comme développé
une obsession pour cette histoire j'ai
fait des recherches par des jaugeurs
dorment plus la nuit et j'ai décidé d'en
parler sur ma chaîne youtube - c'était
vraiment une obsession et j'essaie d'en
parler sur la scène parce que cette
histoire comme l avait jamais été
vraiment traduite et c'est un gros
mystère aux états unis mais bon français
on n'en parle pas beaucoup donc je
voulais le partager avec mes abonnés et
dans cette histoire ait eu quand même
succès donc je pense que oui et vous
avez l'air d'être plus suivi en france
qu'au québec et apparemment il ya rien
il ya un public en france qui est très
très faim friands de ces histoires de
faits divers
ouais mais c'est 66 pour sané des
français qui me suivaient ta maman et je
pense que c'est vraiment je suis un
effet cause à effet le jeu vidéo youtube
a reconnu qui ont parlé de moi mais je
pense aussi que en france vous avez cet
intérêt qu'on a un petit peu moins au
québec peut-être vous avez beaucoup
d'émissions et lors du solaire du crime
ou faites entrer l'accusé basé sa d'or
pour moi même on apprenait
nécessairement ouais alors d'en garder
l'oeil ouvert
gardez l'oeil ouvert pourquoi parce que
comme les gens ont disparu en garde
toujours l'espoir dans certains cas
qu'il réapparaisse
donc il faut garder l'oeil ouvert vous
racontez quinze histoires de disparition
mystérieuse et vous dites que votre
préférée concerne reg ricard qui était
une sorte de procureur de la république
l'équivalent pour les états unis alors
ce qui est très troublant c'est que
comme il est procureur de la république
la police met vraiment le paquet pour le
retrouver or ça ne marche pas c'est
extrêmement romanès puisque sa
disparition reproduit quelque chose
qu'il a lu dans un livre on sait qu'il a
lu ce livre
il ya énormément d'éléments troublants
et même avec tous les moyens de la
police il ya énormément de disparition
qui reste inexpliquée donc c'est ça
donne beaucoup d'espoir as
ils veulent faire le crime parfait c'est
possible de faire disparaître enfin gris
gris car on sais pas peut-être qu'il a
dit c'est fait disparaître lui-même ou
complètement fin on se dit que quand
même avec tous les moyens scientifiques
les nouveaux moyens de la police on doit
pouvoir retrouver des gens ce n'est pas
du tout le cas il ya des milliers de
disparitions inexpliquées
oui comment bonne question mais c'est
sûr que j'ai l'impression qu'il y en a
tellement qu'on vient qu'on a fait comme
si on y porte plus tellement attention
il y en a à chaque jour par exemple aux
canards au canada je pense que c'est une
cinquantaine de disparition par jour
je sais pas si les parties peuvent
vraiment cherché pendant 10 à 1000 je
veux dire on passe déjà à autre chose
c'est très triste je pense que c'est un
peu sur mon livre c'est de pas fait de
ne pas laisser ces histoires tombé dans
l'oubli parce qu'on est beaucoup trop je
pense qu'il y en a à l'origine question
à vous poser
il y avait un duo de comiques dans les
incendies qui s'appelait frère aîné il y
en a un qui a disparu qui s'appelait
teddy vrignaud sur les bons qu'est-il
devenu
non mais c'est parce qu'il était très
connue formant un duo ou non mais ça a
l'air d'être une blague mais c'est vrai
la région elle était de l'île et andré
cayatte yves regnault et y passer quand
j'étais petit on les voyait à la
télévision où le temps toutes les
semaines aujourd'hui comme par exemple
les chevaliers du fiel par exemple et un
jour il y en a un des deux qui a disparu
dans les années soixante seize 117 et on
ne l'a jamais retrouvée donc si vous
voulez bien enquêté sur lui
quatre ans est oui mais avec beaucoup
d'information du ministère la sec ne
connaissais pas sachant que londres est
derrière lui est décédé récemment sans
jamais savoir ce qu'est devenu son
binôme chambre et j'ai une question mais
c'est quelqu'un d'un peu plus qu'avoir
de nous dans le temps
xavier dupont de ligonnès alors là c'est
la sphère françaises emblématiques
est-ce que vous avez une théorie au
sujet si vous pouviez nous le révéler
alors là pour l'aude et match alors que
là on sait pourquoi il est parti alors
que là le type dont je te parlais on ait
aucune raison d'ailleurs
et ça est-ce que vous êtes intéressé
xavier dupont de ligonnès à ce cas
emblématique puisque vous avez un nous
en tirer une vidéo sur le sujet elle été
surprise par exemple sa soeur croyait
même que les corps qu'on avait retrouvé
cette épaule est bon et c'est vraiment
une histoire incroyable j'ai eu comme
une période de temps que je pensais
qu'ils étaient vraiment partie dans la
cia et avec sa famille
j'ai l'impression que n'importe quel
article qu'on va lire ça va nous donner
comme une petite idée de ce qu'est ce
qui s'est passé mais on sens d'opinion
le à travers les articles qu'on lit sur
le sujet je sais pas je pense que j'ai
décidé de s'en fait moi je pense que
peut-être caché quelque part c'est quand
même facile on pense que ça doit
tellement d'ici l'an 2020 de disparaître
je ne pense pas que ça va aussi des
familles de victimes qui vous contactent
directement c'est une grosse
responsabilité parce que vous êtes leurs
derniers espoirs
la police a échoué la science a échoué
ils viennent vers vous qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez leur apporter concrètement
c'est horrible ans et ceux qui aiment
walla youtube 'les la dernière est ce
pas et ça m'a surpris au départ comme
contact m'a fait mes vidéos il ya des
vidéos qui sont visionnées par sept cent
mille personnes
je sais pas les côtes d'écouté en france
à l'heure des nouvelles
au canada c'est un petit peu moins mais
sept cent mille personnes ces sept cent
mille personnes de plus qui sont au
courant de cette histoire
ces sept cent mille personnes qui vont
se rappeler et cette journée là il ya
mon nom qui agissent mais étrangement
est-ce qu'ils prêtent coupable bon je
pense que c'est ça un peu l'intérêt de
ma chaîne youtube de mon livre je résume
ces histoires je mets des photos oui
j'ai une question à vous poser pardon je
vous interromps vous avez 700000
followers sur youtube a semblé beaucoup
700 4 1 4 1 c'est beaucoup mais le nom
de follower n'a jamais tout le temps
rimer avec qualité de quelle compétence
vous prévalez vous parce que votre livre
est intéressant dans le sens où vous
traiter l'histoire dont on n'a pas tout
le temps en temps les parler c'est
beaucoup d'histoires
autre un portique donc on ne connaît pas
tout et après vous faites des
suppositions complètement
abracadabrantesque des effets et
regretté jacques chirac
de quelle posture êtes vous pour vous
faire de telle déduction qui sont
parfois vraiment très limite esclave à
être diplômés de criminologie question
de compétences donc c'est juste de jus
de crâne chez vous tout seul dans leur
diplôme de youtube biologie [ __ ] à paris
mais je pense que moi j'ai le dit
d'avant-garde j'ai aucune prétention en
faisant ce que je fais je raconte une
histoire
moi en tant que la fille que passé des
semaines à rechercher sur un sujet j'ai
lu toutes les théories possibles je les
raconte
je prends position parfois mais c'est
toujours sans prétention 27e riaj pas
vous attaquez vous êtes extrêmement
sympathique vos théories c'est selon moi
j'aime à penser que j'aimerais croire
qu'il est vivant c'est bien gentil mais
c'est ce qui manque à votre voix dans
votre bouquin il manque la vie d'un vrai
crime et de logue qui aurait pu
compléter votre jugement qui n'est que
de la posture et de l'impression pour le
deuxième à être se fait après ans et
s'appelle wec merci parce que vous savez
les faits divers c'est comme le foot
pendant la coupe du monde
tout le monde pense pouvoir être
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france il
ya tout le monde pense être l'enquêteur
qui va trouver l'assassin mais je pense
pouvoir au delà de ça il faut voir que
je pense que j'apporte un peu de positif
à ces familles par exemple une fille de
22 20 ans qui a disparu en 90 sa famille
et découragés parce que plus personne ne
s'en occupe pas que je pense que faut
voir au delà de l'aspect criminel non
mais je donne la vie comme dangereux à
la région pour toucher ça avec des
pincettes vous vendez ainsi un espoir
qui corroboraient a rien de technique et
de scientifiques
non mais vous dites que vous l'avez dit
vous-même ça que c'est quand même une
matière un petit peu explosif que vous
manipulez belge passe l'a fait avec
beaucoup de respect et la plupart des
familles avec qui sont en contact sont
extrêmement reconnaissante et j'ai
toujours je parle beaucoup avec des
avertissements écoutez moi je racontais
sort chez moi salut succès comme
démesuré mais démesurée à ce que je
m'attendais en tout cas c'est catherine
rambert disparaît demain on saura vertus
secours
llorenti score une puce qui se dégagera
parmi toutes les autres séries et on
parlait d'ailleurs de faux espoirs
c'était de calais pour à pauline lafont
par exemple quand c'est le moment pensé
à l'abandon le lendemain on voyait que
c'était pas le cas est-ce que vous avez
aidé à résoudre chacun de ma manière je
fais du bénévolat pour un site qui
s'appelle du network
je passe une vingtaine d'heures par
semaine
je travaille pour la france pour le
canada et l'espagne en fait moi je mets
à jour des cas de disparitions se créer
des profils pour les personnes disparues
et j'essaie de faire des matches entre
les personnes retrouvées et disparus bon
c'est un peu complexe
non j'ai pas résolu deux cas mais c'est
ce que je fais pour aider mais parce que
ça pourrait être quelque chose ne
serait-ce que se trouve qu'à priori il
ya 99 9% de chances quand nous regardons
ça de près c'est passé une partie de sa
vie à faire quelque chose qui n'aura pas
d'aboutissement
mais faut que quelqu'un le fasse il est
présent parce qu'un ou plusieurs qui s'y
intéressent ça nous frustre pas de se
dire à l'arrivée il ya peu de chance
quand même que ça marche ou ça vous
savez pas épuisé à chercher ça va c'est
vraiment passionnant à lire par exemple
le cas de jean spengler et jean spengler
elle est là ce qui lui est arrivé
rappelle beaucoup l'histoire du dahlia
noir vaut vous l'expliquer donc aux as
as ça rapproche de ellroy
donc on retombe dans cette énigme donc à
une énigme irrésolue il ya une deuxième
énigme irrésolue elle laisse un mot il
est question de kirk comme elle a tourné
avec kirk douglas on se demandait ce que
kirk douglas en fait dont il a un alibi
n'a rien à voir avec l'histoire et c'est
quand même des tranches de vie parfois
passé que vous arrivez à ressusciter moi
je trouve que vous faites de manière
passionnante mais c'est intime rc
comment est ce que les familles se
rassurent le plus volontiers par
l'hypothèse du suicide de la fugue et
qui est que le fils ou la fille est
installé quelque part très loin et dans
ses thèses de l'assassinât vient
toujours en dernier et n'ont pas
nécessairement est par exemple aussi
dans mon livre un petit garçon de 14 ans
qui a disparu s'était beaucoup en
contact avec son père et dit je peux pas
que j'espère qu'il en a envie mais en
même temps je peux pas croire qu'ils qui
m'a jamais contacté après dix ans et on
était tellement proches et des jours qui
il dit il avait retrouvé un corps il
pensait que c'était pendant un moment on
pensait que c'était son fils il dit
j'espérais presque ça soit lui par une
conclusion
et quand la joie s'incarne dans un
cadavre on voit le niveau désespoir qui
perdu des gens aux essais je prends pas
seuls les gens parce que je pense avec
les esprits mais pas du tout n'avait pas
peur - vous pouvez découvrir quand vous
enquêtez comme ça non vous avez jamais
peur mais je veux en même temps ce pas
du travail journalistique japon - c'est
plus et ça met dans la tête un
vocabulaire quand même disparition sort
comme ici devient comme un peu oui en
tant que femme surtout on devrait en
2020 on est vraiment au courant des
dangers de la société parce que c'est
mais non je pense que je viens plus
prudentes même les abonnés du ter de
plus je regarde des vidéos je fais plus
confiance à n'importe qui voilà bien un
effet positif je chante quand on perd
quand tu es un enfant disparu il a 12
ans et les parents
par exemple j'ai vu qu'il y avait des
jeunes enfants qui ont disparu en 1982
est ce que les parents aujourd'hui en
2020 pensent à leur fils avec le visage
qu'ils avaient en 1982 où est ce qu'ils
savent que c'est un type de 50 ans est
ce qu'ils arrivent à transformer le
dernier souvenir
en adulte 2,50 en baisse 40 ans ce
qu'elle père du petit enzo gaz d'in que
je parle la pire chose serait de passer
dans la rue à côté de mon fils a des
poils heures à convaincre donc je pense
que c'est comme floue j'imagine qu'ils
s'imaginent encore leur fille et les
logiciels qui a aujourd'hui je suis
désolé ricains eu lieu vous savez on a
des petits logiciels qui permettent de
vie en accéléré
est ce qu'il ya des familles qui ont été
tentés d'appliquer sa sur leurs enfants
pour voir à quoi il ressemblerait
aujourd'hui ne sais pas non mais oh bah
comme qui avait pas être celui là
ouais paru dans le minnesota en france
on a un exemple aussi christelle mouzin
mouzin qu'elles sont elles-mêmes les
parents ont fait des projections sont
son âge pour voir s'élever encore pour
la reconnaître aujourd'hui c'est le
jeune fille quelle histoire
le double peine et ils sont toujours pas
ils sont toujours en attente
je me demande si ça sert vraiment si on
veut retrouver des gens grâce à des
portraits robots qu'on a fait je pense
pas non mais c'est le nettoyage une
dernière question qui a rien à voir avec
notre sujet mais ya un mois vous étiez
l'invité d'anne roumanoff en même temps
benjamin griveaux de savoir si vous avez
échangé avec lui par la suite après
l'émission
non mais c'est dommage on était aussi je
rappelle la parution de votre livre
garder l'oeil ouvert c'est paru aux
éditions de l'homme et votre blog
s'intitule foin et merci d'être venu
nous en parle et merci aux puritains
[Applaudissements]